south some of you may be wondering did
they just have nothing else to talk
about today why are they playing
something about cam newton is this about
cam newton is he going back to the
patriots no this is about matt rule last
year he talked about his quarterback who
at the time was his quarterback this
year he's talking about his quarterback
some more here he is from yesterday
meeting with the media and talking about
teddy bridgewater
teddy is a tremendous professional and
tremendous teddy's a tremendous person
and so um you know he i think he i can't
speak for him i think he's controlling
what he can control and um he's having a
great offseason i'm sure i can't wait to
get him back here and i think he's
determined to play his best football
next year
as far as where he stands with us i mean
he's our quarterback and uh you know
nothing's you know nothing's changed
since the end of the off season
um you know it's really really not much
that from where we started you know last
you know at the end of the year you know
teddy's like i said he's a true
professional i don't
he didn't unfollow me you know i mean i
think he's just at a po
i wouldn't read too much into anything
you know i think you know he's in a
moment right now where
he's just kind of controlling what he
can control uh focusing on himself
focusing on his family and
i know he'll uh i know he's when he gets
back here he'll he'll be ready to go
he's our quarterback nothing's changed
since the offseason no it hasn't changed
yet and not for lack of trying they made
no secret of the fact that they tried to
get matthew stafford right they would
like to get to sean watson right they
would probably like to get russell
wilson if he was in play although we
raised the point the other day scott
fitter or the new gm came from seattle
maybe maybe he's not interested in
giving up what's necessary to get
russell wilson but they clearly are
motivated to get a franchise quarterback
they've done nothing to contain that
they've done nothing to put that story
out i mean think about it if the
buccaneers
had been linked to efforts to get desean
watson or matthew stafford they would
have mobilized immediately to save you
lost your damn minds we have tom brady
there was nothing like that by the
panthers to throw water on any of these
stories and and matt rule i think he
learned his lesson last year i think he
was a little too effusive about cam
newton he was much more muted and you
could read between the tea leaves that
you would say yesterday that that
everything he said was equivocal and
conditional he said the right words he's
trying to show respect to teddy
bridgewater but we all know they're
trying to find a better quarterback no
doubt and and you know here's when you
want to read between the tea leaves
there
the biggest thing is this to me when you
listen back to those quotes and
everything he said there
and i i always go to this when the first
thing out of the coach's mind or out of
his mouth
is
nothing to do with what he is on the
football field and it's oh he's a great
person and he's a great leader and you
know he's a true professional
that tells you it all
you know if it was a truly talented we
love this guy that oh he's one of the
best there is he's got this great that
great this great right when you start
with that that's where sometimes where
even in the draft process i hear guys go
down that line i want to go are you
listening to yourself you've made three
points about the player and none of it
has to do with on the field so there's
you're showing bias and you're scouting
right there well there they're just
showing i mean he's saying it to you
yeah they like all the intangibles but
there's tangibles on you know
on the field that are less than and
listen you're going to look at these
stats and all that and that's hey it's
not bad okay yeah that's pretty good it
doesn't matter it's like you and i have
talked about million times those
turnovers happened in the worst of times
there was
way more plays and yards and touchdowns
there to be had by that carolina
panthers offense with the weaponry they
had and that's where i think carolina
goes back to it and goes no we're too
damn good you know to be thrown for 248
yards per game and only 15 touchdown
passes with last year they might have
had the best receiving trio in football
or it's up there in that conversation
you know so again teddy bridgewater i
love the story the human being and all
that but he's no more than a bridge year
quarterback or a really high-end backup
in my opinion and i think carolina came
to that you know justification and i
would expect them to still be in the
quarterback market whether it's the
draft or a trade here as we go on
but what were they thinking when they
gave him a three-year 66 million dollar
contract he still got a lot of
guaranteed money this i don't know i did
well one they got into a guy hey he
knows our system
all that
you know i i i've thought like oh wait
you got him from a guy in your division
did you guys call sean payton and he
told you how awesome he was and sold it
because he was like yeah you guys have
him i don't want you getting anybody too
talented in our division jetty
bridgewater is great he'll know your
offense and do all those things you know
i think they were in a spot where they
didn't know what to do last year there
wasn't anybody quite available at the
time and all of that so yeah they're
going to end up wasting some money on
teddy bridgewater there's no doubt about
that but uh i don't expect him to be the
quarterback as the off-season goes on i
think they draft someone at a number
eight or like you said the desean watson
thing becomes very real and again we
haven't heard deshaun watson
any link to him wanting to go to
carolina that'd be one team i've
continued to say if i were him or i was
advising him i'd go hey look at this
carolina team a little harder you could
go there and kind of be superman in a
hurry and the team itself is not far
behind to where they can be legit here
in the next two to three years
you mentioned sean payton and what he
may have said last year about teddy
bridgewater before the panthers signed
him i i kind of wondered the same right
thing when when he was with us five
weeks ago joe brown
winston yeah and but talking about
jameis winston and going on about james
winston like if this is the guy you
really want to keep
should you should you really be
that over the top with your praise for
jameis winston or should you be trying
to get him signed a new contract and
hold the praise for the day that you
have the press conference announcing
that jameis winston staying with the
team so look that this is the game that
they play this is the life that they've
chosen
sometimes you get the truth sometimes
you don't it's always better
strategically to conceal the truth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports